[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le 7-8 journal de tv 78
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez pour
cette édition du mardi 7 mai voici les
titres
l'hommage de aux 57 pompiers des
yvelines le département les a
récompensés à la mi journée ils ont pour
la plupart combattu les flammes lors de
l' incendie de la cathédrale notre dame
de paris
ces hommes ont également lutter contre
la fuite d'hydrocarbures à auteuil est
et voici sans avoir les 74 ans de la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale seront
commémorés ce mercredi 8 mai pour
l'occasion un témoin de la période se
confie à tv 78 et l'irb à 90 ans raconte
le conflit attrape occupation allemande
bombardement de la ville
il nous a aussi livré son regard sur le
contexte actuel et puis des jeunes de la
maison des enfants et parents de la
verrière signe ce film un court métrage
pour sensibiliser au harcèlement
scolaire qui touche un élève sur dix en
france
la vidéo est désormais diffusé dans les
écoles collèges ou lors de débats ces
jeunes sont nos invités
un mot de santé pour débuter avec ces
chiffres inquiétants sur cette maladie
qui touche les poumons la tuberculose
est en augmentation dans la région
parisienne est d'après santé publique
france le nombre de cas est en hausse de
10% entre 2015 et 2017 est la maladie
est deux fois plus répandu sur le
territoire francilien que dans le reste
du pays ce sont les personnes en
situation de précarité de promiscuité
qui sont les plus concernés la
tuberculose se soigne en moyenne sur 6
mois avec plusieurs antibiotiques
le département des yvelines a rendu
hommage ce midi à ces soldats du feu 57
d'entre eux ont reçu une médaille pour
avoir combattu un incendie de notre dame
de paris et lutter contre la fuite de
pétrole à auteuil est et boissy sans
avoir le reportage de nicolas landry et
d'aurélien des sapeurs-pompiers blinois
distingués pour leurs récentes actions
notamment pour avoir aidé à sauver le
beffroi nord de notre dame de paris
il y a quelques années le conseil
départemental des yvelines avait fait
l'acquisition de deux bras élévateur de
46 mètres de haut
une aide précieuse le 15 avril dernier
dans la capitale dire notre fierté
et dire aux yvelinois pouvait être fier
votre argent a été bien utilisé
ça a coûté par yvelinois 70 centimes
d'euro
voyez cet argent
heureusement qu'on a dépensé 57
sapeurs-pompiers vinon ont reçu une
médaille
c'est le cas de l'adjudant steve venot
il est resté plus de sept heures dans
une nacelle pour lutter contre
l'insomnie de notre dame de paris
on a eu une action plus qu'efficace
ce soir là donc on est assez fiers déjà
des revenus parce que dans une carrière
de pompier je pense que l'on fera pas
l'intervention majeur aussi importante
assez souvent on est fière aussi d'avoir
préservé
cette structure ce bâtiment car ça fait
partie de notre histoire c'est un peu
dommage imaginer versailles son château
on n'imagine pas lors de cette cérémonie
un hommage a également été rendu aux
sapeurs pompiers mobilisés le 25 février
dernier lors de la rupture du pipeline à
auteuil et boissy sans avoir moi j'ai
été engagé l'après midi
effectivement pour coordonner les
opérations de pompage
suite à la rupture du 'pipeline' ça fait
40 ans je suis sapeur pompier c'est la
première fois que j'intervenais sur une
rupture de paille très fier pour le
centre de secours
et puis très fier pour
à titre personnel l'assurance c'est
toujours une fierté de recevoir une
médaille
au total près de 4000 personnes au sein
du service départemental d'incendié et
de secours oeuvre au quotidien pour la
sécurité des yvelinois
demain nous commémorons le 74e
anniversaire de la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale le 8 mai 1945
l'allemagne nazie capitulait signant la
victoire des alliés mettant fin au
conflit le plus meurtrier de l'histoire
point stratégique en raison de son
chemin de fer trappe qui a beaucoup
souffert pendant la guerre des
bombardements alliés détruisant deux
tiers de la ville pour tv 78 en habitant
de longue date
elie robin se souvient de cette période
et se confie sur le contexte actuel
regarder cet entretien les images sont
signées nicolas landry bonjour et l'irb
un bon jour je merci de nous recevoir
chez vous à la veille de ces
commémorations du 8 mai 1945 de la fin
de cette seconde guerre mondiale
justement la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale qui marque le début de la paix
la paix qui est une culture pour vous
vous avez été longtemps militant du
mouvement de la paix secrétaire sur la
ville de trappes de ce mouvement de
l'appel
vous n'avez qu'une dizaine d'années
lorsque le conflit mondiale éclate en
septembre 1939 à l'époque malgré votre
jeune âge vous étiez déjà militant alors
en tout cas vous participiez par exemple
aux collectes de lait pour les enfants
des républicains espagnols
c'était la vie et cette fibre militants
ça va ça vous a toujours ça vous a
toujours habité c'était si vous voulez
on n'en parle plus jamais être savez il
ya eu les vaillants et vaillante après
la guerre et avant la guerre ça
s'appelait mon camarade bon si nos
parents qui nous gérer lorsque l'on
avait et bon il fallait faire des
actions humaines alors en 39 septembre
1939 la guerre éclate cette seconde
guerre mondiale qui va tourner très vite
al'avantage de l'allemagne nazie
l'armistice est signé le 22 juin 1940
débute alors cette période d'occupation
de la france avant cette libération qui
interviendra bien plus tard à l'été 1944
quels souvenirs vous gardez de cette
période d'occupation par l'allemagne est
certaine peur parce que j'allais à
versailles à l'école à versailles et à
jules ferry est sûr que ont rencontrés
sur la route dans les trains outre des
les allemands officiellement ou pas et
il fallait quand même pas trop dire
déroger aux règles ont par contre à
l'école jules-ferry à versailles
on se sentait relativement libre femmes
je peux même dire que mon prof
d'allemand et elle n'a jamais usé de la
victoire allemande pour nous faire
découvrir monsieur très gentil
ben justement sur l'école c'est un fait
que vous avez compté au journal
l'humanité dans les années 2000 alors en
1942 vous avez toujours une dizaine
d'années lorsque vous êtes à l'école le
premier de la classe c'est un copain
vous le dit un copain juifs et lors de
la distribution des prix qui se fait à
l'époque en présence des officiels vous
organisez
une manifestation vous vous lever et
vous applaudissez copa pas du tout non
ça a été ça n'a pas c'était la
distribution des prix c'était à
versailles et il y avait tous les
collèges lycées et j acques le premier
le deuxième qui avait un prix et il y
avait un tas jules-ferry une école
commerciale enfin est dedans il y avait
un élève qui était juif n'était pas du
tout dans ma classe soit d'accord et il
a été premier de sa classe il ait
participé à la distribution des prix
enfin ils étaient honorés et quand on
l'a quand il y la ville le l'insigne
juifs obligatoires et quand il s'est
présenté qu'il pour recevoir son prix
tout le monde s'est levé dans l'eure
dans la salle c'était impressionnant
mais c'était pas je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire c'était organisé je crois
que c'était spontané c'est un geste qui
pourrait paraître banale
aujourd'hui à l'époque en tout cas comme
on était forcément dans ce contexte
juillet juste avant la période des
grandes rave puisqu'on en 1942 les
grands grave de l'été 1942 avant le
début de la choix c'est un geste déjà de
résistance même si vous étiez jeune à
l'époque soutenir un gentil
parce qu'on était quand même des monts
bain
pas mais il y avait aucune préparation
tout au moins à ma connaissance un c je
pense parce que s'il y avait eu une
préparation il y avait tellement d'école
tellement de n'avait pas de côté
organisé c'était spontané
ar oui oui oui c'était impressionnant
j'ai eu aussi pendant cette période
un de mes meilleurs camarades alors
parce qu'il habitait trappe son grand
père et sa grand mère était à trappes
qui s'appelait jacques booba ce qui lui
a été arrêté et n'est jamais revenue
et il travaillait dans la résistance
mais je crois pour le compte de la croix
rouge
si vous les voyez s'il c'est un
organisme j'irai très indépendant mais
très nationale quoi quand même hélas il
est parvenu
vous disiez vous étiez à l'école à à
versailles vous êtes resté pendant 7 à 2
à dire dans cette ville de trappes la
ville de trappes qui a particulièrement
parties en ont souffert il ya eu un
bombardement en 1944 juste avant le
débarquement quelques quelques jours
avant des arguments du 6 juin oui il ya
trois bombardements et le 6 mars qui est
extrêmement important bien sûr sa visée
le transport la gare de trappes et le
transport du matériel au triage de
trappes militaire c'était le premier le
6 mars le deuxième c'est et le 1er juin
et le troisième c'était le 3 juin
mais entre temps il y avait souvent de
trois avions anglais ou américains qui
passent et qui file un coup mais trois
gros bombardements ca c'est à ces dates
là c'était une cité cheminote à l'époque
trap est ce qu'il y avait une fibre
résistante parmi ces cheminots oui oui
je
oui il y avait même des déportés mon
père n'a pas fait une énorme action
résistante thomas connaissant souvent
par contre ici avec transporter des
documents pour les résistants qui était
organisée pour distribuer des tracts
pour faire connaître mais jean selles
l'âge et non c'est pas plus mon coeur en
parlait jamais il est électricien je
crois il avait le droit de sortir du
coup la nuit c'est ça c'est une
autorisation type d'électricien c'est
qu'on avait besoin de lui la nuit alors
il sortait quand on l'appelait y avait
pas de téléphone à cette époque là
c'était un agent qui venait avec sa
petite lampe à pétrole lui dire bah tu
viens il ya tel incident électrique au
dépôt ou au triage ici rendait avec lui
aussi sa lampe à pétrole
parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
éclairages dans la villa le fait
d'ailleurs qu'il est une autorisation
allemande de circuler la nuit avec lui
permettait de faire ces transports pour
la résistance à choquer c'est pour ça
qu'on l'avait qui faisait ce travail il
était là mais le droit demain c'est la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale que
l'on commémorera cette capitulation
allemande du 8 mai 1945 un conflit qui a
fait plus de 60 millions de morts
certains historiens monte même à 85
millions de morts sur le le bilan à la
fin de la guerre à l'époque votre état
d'esprit est ce que c'était du
soulagement vous pensiez déjà à l'avenir
à ce que ce massacre ne se reproduise
plus vous pensiez déjà
ça vous aviez les sports peut-être que
ça ne se reproduise sur les avaient
interrogés on aurait vraisemblablement
répondu que c'était la dernière garde
toujours guère que tout le monde avait
compris
et là ça me paraît pas vrai en 1949 vous
vous mobiliser pour l'appel de stockholm
c'est ça la pelle contre l'armement
nucléaire vous sentiez déjà que cet
armement cette course à l'armement
nucléaire pouvait déjà une nouvelle
menace pour la paix on était sortis
d'une guerre dans en europe bien sûr
parce qu'il y avait comme y avait déjà
pu y avait aussi l'asie le japon il y
avait sur et on continuer à s'armer
bon on continue à rechercher aussi
varman même du des matériels militaires
ou nucléaires
donc il était normal je crois de
d'essayer de freiner ce mouvement de
préparation une future une future gare
le devoir de mémoire c'est un terme
qu'on entend souvent
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il faut d'après
vous continuer il faut ça c'est quelque
chose de primordial continuent de
l'entretenir auprès des jeunes il ne
faut pas cesser de se souvenir de ceux
qui se sont sacrifiés pour avoir c'est
pas un
est-ce que l'apl est acquise d'après
vous il faut toujours se battre lors
elle pense que c'est tonnelle et manqué
de que l'on doit utiliser
je pense quand même que l'essentiel
étape et primaires c'est de dire que
tant qu'on veut vendre énormément de
matériel de guerre
on prend le risque qu'ils soient utiles
que le matériel soit utilisée et que il
ya d'autres voir lorsqu'il ya des des
différends entre deux pays
on peut aussi rechercher la paix et ce
sera ma dernière question élire au bain
vous pensez aussi aujourd'hui que cette
paix est menacée quand on voit en europe
dans différents pays la montée la percée
de l'extrême droite certains pays sont
d'ailleurs gouverné par des
gouvernements d'extrême droite comme en
italie ce que ça ça vous inquiète
aujourd'hui oui sur 24 sans aucun doute
les les villes de calais pays de l'est
la ce
après l'italie qui les blesse c'est que
c'est quand même très grave même chez
nous des sentiments l'humanisme les
sentiments de père ne prévaut pas mais
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de doute il
faut lutter contre les armements
nucléaires contre la vente des armements
et sur lui de contrôler la vente faut du
thé contre la créa leur création il ya
autre chose à faire pour réguler le
peuple et les peuples
1 je crois merci et les romains dans ce
témoignage arabe je vous en prie et pour
ces commémorations du 8 mai 1945 des
cérémonies se tiendront dans toute les
yvelines le programme chez vous à
consulter sur le site internet de votre
commune
emmanuel macron l'a annoncé lors de la
conférence de presse post grand débat
national ils eurent à un nouvel acte de
la décentralisation comprenez transférer
plus de compétences aux collectivités
locales un acte qui portera sur le
logement le transport et la transition
écologique et de son côté la mif
l'association des maires d'ile-de-france
qui a tenu récemment son salon à paris
fixe six grands principes pour permettre
cette nouvelle décentralisation
parmi les priorités donner davantage de
souplesse pour plus d'autonomie
d'organisation local - d'évolution
imposé pour ne pas stopper le
développement des projets conforter les
mères dans leur rôle de pivot ou encore
renforcer les synergies au sein du bloc
communal l'amif demande au président
d'être associés à la réflexion de cet
acte de la décentralisation
elle a d'ores et déjà lancé un goût un
groupe de travail sur le sujet la
direction à présent vélizy 2 qui a connu
ces derniers mois quelques changements
le centre commercial yvelines on a vu
arriver un nouveau cinéma est un espace
entièrement dédié à la restauration et
aux loisirs une extension de 20 mille
mètres carrés et dont les contours ne
sont présentés par nickel et demi
d'euros la nouvelle extension de vélizy
2 est terminé après l'ouverture début
mars de son nouveau cinéma le centre
commercial a inauguré quelques jours
plus tard une halte gourmande au total
23 restaurant pour manger sur place ou
sur le pouce se sont implantés dans ce
nouvel espace de 5000 m² il y avait de
fortes attentes un autre clientèle
pourra voir
l'offre de restauration c'était une
demande depuis des années parce qu'on a
quand même 50 mille salariés qui
travaillent ici tous les jours à
proximité donc le mili forcément mais
également le week-end parce que nos
piles d'activité sont le samedi et
maintenant le dimanche et on a une
clientèle qui souhaitent se restaurer le
midi le soir avant d'aller au cinéma et
on avait un besoin a besoin important on
avait dix sept points de restauration
donc là on passe à 40
en parallèle de la restauration les
gérants misent également sur les loisirs
ici cette salle d'arcade en réalité
virtuelle propose de vous immerger dans
un monde 2.0 dont vous voyez derrière
moi mais les différentes stations
délimiter chaque client est équipé d'un
casque et de deux manettes reproduisant
mouvement des mains et grâce à ça il va
se plonger dans le monde de son choix
seul ou à plusieurs donc ça peut être
simplement de l'exploration si vous
voulez visiter deux villes dans le monde
n'importe où dans le monde
si vous voulez jouer à différentes
choses voulait faire de l' escalade sur
la baie d'halong au vietnam ou sur les
parois rocheuses des alpes dans des
paysages magnifiques vous pouvez pour
cette nouvelle extension les
propriétaires ont dû mettre près de 140
millions d'euros sur la table
au total plus de 300 emplois ont été
créés durant sa scolarité à un jeune sur
dix est victime de harcèlement scolaire
en france un phénomène qui peut
malheureusement viré au drame c'est pour
contrer ce harcèlement que des jeunes de
la verrière
on se sont prêtés à l'exercice du court
métrage un court métrage de
sensibilisation alors il ya quatre
d'entre eux qui sont autour de la table
à ma gauche léa alia à ma droite wassim
et elysées bonsoir à bout 4 et d'être
accompagné
de momar niang bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes encadrant vous avez encadré ce
projet pour l'association pics neil
alors ça ma première question va
s'adresser à vous comment il s'est monté
ce projet justement en fait c'est la
deuxième édition qu'on fait avec la mère
de la verrière donc donc la même c'est
la maison des enfants et des parents
voilà donc on aura propose un atelier de
courts métrages ça veut dire montrer
montrer aux jeunes de la verrière
comment on peut réaliser un film
commence comment se déroule un film
et voilà c'est la deuxième fois qu'on le
fait et les deux fois ont été couronnés
de succès donc j'espère qu'il y aura une
troisième forme ans alors ce court
métrage la s'inscrit dans un dispositif
national qui s'appelle stop au
harcèlement
pourquoi choisir cette thématique
c'était important pour vous de parler du
harcèlement scolaire
bah c'est quelque chose qui est assez
vraiment d'actualité même si c'est déjà
passé avant mais oui c'est un sujet
important
petit tour de table auprès des enfants
on va commencer avec les a
pourquoi c'était important pour vous
pourquoi y avoir participé à ce projet
ont des enfants c'est grave de ces 10
années et pour leur donner plus d'idées
sur la vidéo qu'on a fait est bon 100%
en a fait cette vidéo elle ya pourquoi y
avoir participé
qu'est ce qui vous a fait plaisir à
participer à ce projet parce que déjà
j'aime bien l'audiovisuel et comme el
hadji les abats c'est pas normal que les
personnes face à face harceler ses
questions harcelé bas ils sont des
biffins à les harceleurs ils sont
débiles de faire ça parce que ça apporte
rien
wassim elysées wassim peut-être
recommencer bah j'ai voulu participer à
ce projet parce qu'il ya encore des
personnes qui se font harceler et ça
devrait normalement cécile les bas parce
que moi j'ai une amie qui sait faire
seul et je voulais
on va peut-être on parlait juste après
on va d'abord regarder un extrait de ce
court métrage je m'appelais ma mère
[Musique]
et si j'avais prévenu mes amis il faut
donc on suit l'histoire et dalia qui est
victime d'harcèlement va la retrouver
dans plusieurs situations dans une
journée classique finalement à l'école
ou des camarades lui vole son portable à
chaque scène il ya un retour en arrière
pour voir ce qu'il se serait passé si
elle y avait parlé de son harcèlement
autour d'elle c'est ça le message à
passer mars et il faut en parler c'est
ça en fait comme on peut le voir dans le
court métrage en fait plus alia on parle
alors par la différente à ses amis
d'abord après je pense à son professeur
à ses parents en fait quand toutes ces
personnes sont courants en fait je pense
que c'est un bon dispositif pour arrêter
le harcèlement alors vraiment en parler
en discuter
vous disiez lisez vous a été confronté
alors en tant que témoin via une amie à
cette thématique du harcèlement c'est ça
harcèlement scolaire
et du coup c'est aussi pour ça vous le
disiez que ça nous tenait à coeur de
participer à ce court métrage vite parce
qu'ils savent que au final elle en a
parlé donc s'arranger et que ça aurait
pu durer encore longtemps cela fait pas
qu'est ce que vous avez appris justement
elysées parle de parler de libérer
finalement cette parole qu'est ce que
vous avez appris en participant à ce
court métrage sur la thématique du
harcèlement léa ou alia wassim peut-être
parce que qu'est ce que tu as appris
qu'en attendant la fin du court métrage
ses terres c'est se laisser faire donc
il faut il faut parler comment ça s'est
déroulé sur cette réalisation
momar comment s'est déroulé l'écriture
le tournage le montage
c'est assez ça s'est fait sur sur trois
jours en fait donc on vient on discute
du sujet avec avec les jeunes apprennent
ils dégagent en fait c'est un
brainstorming et puis après avec tout ça
ah bah on commence l'écriture du
scénario
tous ensemble et puis si si si tout le
monde est d'accord on tombe dans la
foulée et puis ça s'est fait sur en vrai
sur deux jours voilà c'était pendant les
vacances d'octobre
un dernier mot est ce qu'il ya d'autres
projets de ce genre qui sont prévues en
fait nous piquent semaine on travaille
plusieurs villes notamment de 50 ans il
venait donc on fait plusieurs courts
métrages avec avec des jeunes mais c'est
vrai qu'on a commencé avec la mep et
c'est un endroit où on aime bien
travailler et vraiment j'espère pouvoir
faire d'autres projets avec eux
merci momindum merci à l'est à al hicha
elysées et wassim d'être passé sur ce
plateau bravo pour ce court métrage et
vous pouvez le retrouver en intégralité
sur le site de la verrière
on continue de parler filmer cette fois
ci au cinéma une fois n'est pas coutume
petit tour le mardi dans nos salles
obscures saint-quentinoise mercredi
étant férié ce soir présentation de la
programmation cinéma le grenier à sel à
trappes c'est au micro de michael et
demi d'euros
[Musique]
dans notre salle au cinéma le grenier à
sel
le vendredi 10 mai à 20h30 nous
accueillons des courts métrages locaux
des courts métrages qui ont été réalisés
par des saint quentinois des trappistes
et un peu aux autres dans les zones
alentours il y a
une sélection de films qui a été fait
appel à films qui a été fait par
l'association jolie prof donc c'est un
partenariat entre la ville de trappes
cinéma grenier à sel et l'association
jolie prod
les réalisateurs les équipes de films
seront présentes pour parler de leurs
films et vous présenter leur film
il y en a pour à peu près de deux heures
donc ce sera ce vendredi 10 mai à 20h30
pour les autres courts métrages locaux
n'oubliez pas que le vendredi 24 mai à
18h30 il y aura les courts métrages
réalisés dans le cadre du partenariat
que nous avons avec le lycée de la
plaine de nobles donc ce sont des
lycéens apprentis cinéastes qui
viendront présenter leurs films le
vendredi 24 mai à 18h30
à bientôt au cinéma le grenier à sel
[Musique]
et on recevra jeudi d'ailleurs les
organisateurs de cette soirée dédiée aux
courts métrages locaux mélanie pocket
avec moi en plateau mont soir à la
commanderie on se prépare à une
performance et la chorégraphe tatiana
julien recherche des danseurs c'est
votre coup de coeur de la semaine il y à
une seule condition à respecter avoir
plus de 16 ans et être disponible pour
les ateliers préparatoires alors les
dates s'affiche à l'écran mais pas
besoin de pratiquer de la danse tatiana
julien recherche 30 danseurs amateurs
il faut juste être motivé et curieux et
si vous êtes intéressé lors des ateliers
vous mêler aux dix danseurs
professionnels de la compagnie un mot
avec fanny de bray chargé du
développement artistique de la commande
et tatiana julien est en effet une
chorégraphe de danse contemporaine mais
elle avait vraiment envie d'accueillir
un peu toutes les danses pour cet
événement donc parmi ces danseurs y en a
qui viennent plutôt du voguing qui est
un type de danse urbaine
il y en a qui viennent plutôt de la
danse contemporaine et avec ses danseurs
elle va explorer ces différentes choses
et ça va aussi
des coulées de des personnalités un peu
des différents participants et ses
ateliers aboutiront donc à une
performance qui est programmée le 6
juillet et oui après une dernière
répétition tout le monde sera sur scène
à 21 heures les danseurs présenteront un
sip turbulences internes immo avec fanni
avant de découvrir un extrait de la
création tatiana julien l'a présenté le
22 juin 2018 au château de vincennes
dans le cadre du festival monument en
mouvement et du festival june 26 la
chorégraphe et ses danseurs vont
investir et complètement transformé la
commanderie puisque la danse sera
partout on est loin d'un spectacle
classique
les spectateurs seront amenés à mettre
un casque audio ils sont complètement
immergé dans une bande son et ils seront
amenés à déambuler librement dans la
commanderie et au hasard de leurs
promenades
ils vont tomber sur un tenseur dans tel
endroit un groupe de danseurs à notre
endroit
[Musique]
une lueur
quelqu'un
présent simple
quelque chose un jeu d'intention alors
je râle paix je le rappelle les équipes
de la commanderie recherche 30 danseurs
pour postuler rien de plus simple
grégory l'adresse s'affiche en bas de
l'écran mais je crois qu'il vous vend
pour mercy bay l'a dit on vous retrouve
dans un instant pour votre émission le
7-8 culture la fin de ce set 8 journal
on se retrouve dès jeudi 18h pour une
nouvelle édition d'information locale
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]